hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu endlich
mal wieder im neuen video zu einer neuen
karte und zwar geht ein zombie und geht
auch auf mich gegangen ich verschicke
ich habe keine ahnung ich denke oh mein
gott da kommt ein zombie bitte gehen ich
erfahre hier sind auf dich um dich herum
dreht einfach auf mich
und ja das vermindert und töten rast
verbündet habe komme ich helfe dir hier
ist immer noch extrem laut also erstmal
wieder zurück hier willkommen zu einer
neuen nicht ewig bleibt sondern aus dem
germain ja heißt das ganze und
willkommen darüber sollen video auf
seinem kanal genau ich habe jetzt zwei
oder drei wochen nähe zwei wochen kein
video mehr hochladen das war einfach
wegen vor wie klausuren ich hab das
immer mal wieder gesagt dass ein vor wie
clausen dass da keine videos machen
werde weil bildung schule wichtiger als
das ganze leben hier mit komme also als
wir haben so viele bei allen möglichen
netzwerken geschrieben
so richtige lügen verbreitet ein paar
haben gesagt ja seit pcs kaputt gegangen
das habe ich gehört das stimmt und hat
mein pc lebt er ahnung was sie hatten
ich bin ich höre dir was mit einem
schlag krass die wollen wir nochmal
starten und du kannst nicht ein wenig
labern dasteht startup younicos ages
andy king dem snow junge männer dort
werden verschiedene bereiche durch die
welt gehen müssen
hey komm ich übrigens sagen also wir
wollen auf jeden fall nicht bieten
ob das klappen wird ich würze
angeschlagen uns jetzt nicht so einfach
so jetzt beispielsweise sondern einfach
nur wenn wir dann manchmal trollen und
jajaja darauf ein big mac hat man
vergessen
das ist gravierend epic adventure ok
exciting außer sorry for technology
texter und some like this von besonderes
texture pack das ist mit zur map gehabt
der link zur karte ist natürlich in der
beschreibung wenn du dir auch mal spiel
wollte war
nein nicht nur unter gefallen you know
you're ich kann michael es in der
beschreibung auch die personen die uns
den server gemacht hat was haben sonst
noch zu klären hat nur der kombi ist in
der beschreibung
da kommt der nächste barriere und ich
denke die ganzen schilder hier sind ja
egal da steht halt immer dass das ein
besonders tolles adventure wird und nur
wenn wir aber sachen suchen müssen
übersetzt wer das dann würde ich sagen
und sonst auch wenn so etwas gibt wie
gas tränen
das wäre so kraft dann will jetzt aber
weil die wichtigsten schiller
schlechthin
playmobil aus einer falschen oder sex ja
auf jeden fall geht's jetzt weiter mit
videos freundeskreis haben so hier ist
web starts kaktus live online das klingt
nicht gut
auch dieser fall zeigt so hier in dieser
blofeld sagt zu dahin aber man muss hier
hoch voll doof vor allem sebastian das
gastspiel bei dir alter das was gott das
wasser sieht aber auch eben chance
hinterher
heute sieht echt gut aus ich habe nur
noch meine ist stage schlange weil ich
hab auch noch dreieinhalb ein geschenk
für dich übrigens ich auch
ich wünsche euch nicht heute so doch
längst in shampoos ich habe diese blume
geschenk gedacht du wirst du auf mich
geschossen oder so gemeint bin ich immer
für dich da setzen wir müssen hier
runter und dann einfach mal davon im
körper folgen oder erfolgt uns ja ich
glaube ich weniger
er will mit mir haben nebenbei auch noch
auf twitter nachdem gefragt wie ein
gehört dass solch ein konnten wer hd und
da sind auch schon gerade einige
eingetrudelt
ich habe hier zum beispiel gerade mal 1
zum beispiel fragt lara was hälst oder
haltet ihr von fans und von fanpages auf
instagram hat er so muss erläutert
wirklich eine fanpage machen sozialen
page von crafter fans page com ag und
dann entweder eigentlich verschenkt
geschaffen von dem hochladen wo du drauf
bist und dann so mäßig drauf sind
hahaha diesen tollen witzig darauf muss
sich einfach sagen hast du dich
eigentlich getrunken weil du bist glaub
ich immer noch verzaubert
ich bin ich habe ich nicht getrunken ich
bin ich hab ich nicht habe ich noch gar
nicht hoch wenn ich nicht möchte ich
nicht habe ich nicht ich komme gar nicht
hochkochen wofür brauchen jetzt
eigentlich den die sprung verstärkung
weiß nicht für den ersten sprung bei dem
schnee glaube ich also was halten wir
von diesen seiten
ich heiße eigentlich eigentlich finde
ich das cool wenn leute sagen okay ich
mag den ich mache eine seite für den
aber ich hatte letztens zum beispiel den
fall dass einer nicht mal laser luca
hieß also heißt ich zb auf instagram und
der hieß dann irgendwie anders hat
einfach meine bilder hochgeladen dann
immer so ja heute mal chillen am strand
und so ich denke das bin doch ich
richtig komisch was bin ich halt nicht
so cool war einfach meine bilder so
kopiert das ist nicht so cool aber
gemacht wie es gibt eine contra fanpage
auf instagram und wenn man daraus sagt
das ist nicht die offizielle fanpage
dann ist das doch alles vollkommen okay
aber wenn du sowas gesagt wenn bilder
geklaut werden und einfach gesagt werden
dass meine bilder oder wenn soja das
hier ist die offizielle fanpage und
sowas dann fehlt das nicht so gut aber
sonst eigentlich cool wenn ihr so das
macht ja und ich bin also fanpages
allgemein finde ich natürlich auch eine
ziemlich coole sache weiter auch oft
einen blick oder cooles zeug zu einer
großen verfasst hat die leute machen ja
ich bin schon ich habe es geschafft was
sie auf dich wie
wie kann ich jetzt auch ganz entspannt
über das thema quatschen denn ich finds
halt echt cool das manchmal so bild aber
so gemalt werden oder sogar halt sachen
dann auch googles geil weil weil es gibt
da wirklich leute die sind richtig
talentiert und sowas war auch in anderen
sachen sind da richtig kreativ und
wollen das dann zeigen oder sie mögen
einheit wirklich richtig stark und
machen eine fanpage und ich finde so
lange diese fanpage halte ich im namen
eines youtube oder so zum beispiel jetzt
etwas schreiben sagte material ich bin
hier gerade am strand video hat gerade
sagt ist finde ich das eine coole sache
und natürlich sollten die natürlich auch
dem youtuber nicht den namen wecken das
heißt wenn ich meine wegen auf steam
komma der heißen möchte möchte ich nicht
dass irgendjemand anderes mehr weil
einem fan base stellen wir es ja auch so
dass 1000 leute theoretisch kommen hd
heißen können ja ich meine chrome hd ist
auch nicht mein account viele denken da
dies mein account ich glaube da bekommt
auch gut geschenke dadurch dass sie sich
einfach komma genannt hat weiß wie man
das will ich gar nicht denn faker der
der ich bin zum beispiel komme habe das
selbst wenn man das halt auf anderen
plattformen so auch machen würden und
das finde ich halt ist wirklich okay
aber sonst bin ich fan pages bei
willkommen bei der heutigen
selbsthilfegruppe komme was dann dein
problem wir haben schon gehört du hast
deinen stil namen nicht bekommen ich hab
da gucken hoch ich werde den trank
runter dann hat bekommt ist die
sprungkraft und damit habe ich es
geschafft
ach du hattest diese sprungkraft ja ach
so erste wie gerade auch bekommen ja hab
ich jetzt so vielleicht braucht man ja
sogar die sprungkraft ja ja ja die
braucht man sogar und schaffen obwohl
ich habe meine und gar nicht möglich
gewesen
ich habe bogen ich habe zwei herzen wenn
er mich abschießt richtig war sich
einfach auf dich okay ich bin tot
nein
der chor an bord du dich mal zu mir
nehme ich doch nicht ich bin eben
woanders ab heute dich einfach weil ich
bin doch was geht da natürlich nicht
altach das jetzt aber ich wollte nicht
töten aber sowas ist ein sportlich mal
wo bin ich ich stehe oben ein verdammt
ich bin im blog ich bin land lockt ich
bin ich helfe dir vor du bist du mich
ein halbes ich habe ein halbes herz ich
hab das jetzt was krieg welcher für zone
sprung verstärkung schaffe ich habe mich
so erschrocken
es war so laut auf einmal ich werde
einfach jeder wahlen liegen
ich gehe jetzt mal wird jede wette ein
okay ich laufe einfach jetzt wer vom
staat auslosung gesagt ich werde vor dir
wieder oben zu sein bei dem ohne die
shampoos ohne jump ist damit dafür ist
er doch da du spaten hacken hole ich mir
auf den campus nicht da leute passt auf
ich spiele gerade zu anfang an doch mal
und ich werde früher oben sei als
kräftig sag's euch alter ich habe doch
gar kein shampoo ist ja irgendwo ist das
auch eine truhe aber da komme ich ja
nicht hoch jump ist denn da unten ist
sondern mit oder vodou kann eben standes
wo ich gestorben bin ja da wo wir
möchten damit man den schampus wieder
weg bekommt für das leder der andere
musste nochmal zurück laufen ohne jumps
machen komme ja ja ja doch das noch
einen campus ist da noch dran aber der
ihn habe ich da rein gelegt er gönnt ihm
doch dann können die mal richtig hart
und ich habe ich
dies behinderte eltern ich habe mir die
grenzer ich bin gleich wird dabei die
ich bin gleich wieder das mitgebrachte
papa hat was mitgebracht
lostag male immer machen der papa papa
macht mut und ist im bett nicht viel
verkehr ruft papa hatten am anfang war
ich runter schade schade
ok wette verloren ich bin oben gut
machen musste dass ohne schampus machen
nein hawk down foul
müsste es nicht schneiden jetzt ihr seid
meine damen kommen jetzt du mich warten
ich habe auch auf dich gewartet
disney world dieser form santa clause
acht machen aber noch ein bisschen neun
monate meine damen und herren stromberg
archiv
ich glaube ich komme hallo ich brauch
noch milch ja hab ich ne und behält auch
das sauer golde von jörg haider da
hinten ist ein trieb er beobachtet und
schon die ganze zeit kommen hoch dass
das mal den besser machen lasst das mal
besser machen
kaum ist der papa da war ich bin tot ich
bin tot ich bin tot
ich bin sowieso ich kriege ich nie ein
checkpoint ich hier wollte ich auch
gerne fragen war das ist dass wir können
das da hinten ist der checkpoint glaube
ich da steht der jackpot erhält also
check point software machen das ist
einfach abwechselnd mit worten kann erst
mal machst du ich kann man ganz gut mal
wieder auf dem thema neu
die weiteren erste begegnung mit einem
youtubes da bestimmen erstmal war doch
jetzt jetzt die erste begegnung mit
einem youtube star in welchem sinne
jetzt mit aufnahme oder was meinst du
denn real life begegnung will ich dann
junge rastlos mit diesem ding da hat 48
doch tat ich mal vor keine ahnung also
egal denn ich weiß war der abt ich
fand's halt allgemein sehr cool ich habe
da jemand in hamburg damals getroffen
das war alberto kann es halt ziemlich
cool dass die welt sag ich mal so klein
ist man sich halt wirklich mal trifft so
leute die man auf youtube verfolgt die
pizza die man dann halt wirklich mal ein
echter irgendwie trifft obwohl das gar
nicht eingeplant hat also das fand ich
halt man las dass das fand ich halt
wirklich ziemlich geil und dabei weiß
schon ganz dabei hatte ich auch noch
keine youtube-videos oder sowie online
und das war nicht alles schon ziemlich
cool und das aber war jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie was mega unglaublich ist also
aber es war ein objekt das war auf jeden
fall starker sprung von event war damit
der erste begegnung meine erste
begegnung so in real life mit einem mit
einem youtuber war den als ich mit dem
vor zwei jahren nehme mittlerweile ist
es eineinhalb jahren auf dem video david
wertung kommen wird man den knopf die
ganze zeit ehrlich wenn man jeden
quatsch dass die mittel die wir nutzen
das ist schiiten finde ich drücke drauf
ich drücke die anzahl draufgabe machst
du nicht du bist du bei dir was trainer
ok vor zwei jahren
erst jetzt konnten wir ja ich hab dann
war dann den habe ich dann getroffen da
war ich ja killer ich liebe dich
er warte warte warte mal warte warte mal
vom aus das bett ich will da rein du
machst die zeit runter nein das war
eigentlich ganz billig und die erste
begegnung mit unserem youtube star floyd
auch damals da auf dem video day auf
visueller sonst so innenstadt ja auch
mit denen in der stadt habe ich noch nie
so irgendwen gesehen aber sonst würde
ich auch sagen meine lieben freunde des
paars mit der erste wieso die zweite
findet morgen auf gomez kanal oder will
ich sagen macht's gut bis zum nächsten
mal und wenn es euch gefallen hat könnte
hier eine bewertung lassen und so genau
also haut rein und schon folgen wenn
ihre themen schreiben wollt und mit